اذا نظرت الاستماع ليلا فقد ترع عددا
كبيرا من النجوم او قد لا ترى نجوما على
الاطلاق والسبب التلوث الضوئي ففي المدن
والمناطق ذات الكثافه السكانيه العاليه من
المستحيل تقريبا رؤيه النجوم تمتد دوره
حياه النجم الى مليارات السنين وكا
قاعده ما زاد حجم النجم كلما كان عمره
اكثر تتالق بعض النجوم اكثر من غيرها وسبب
سطوعها هو مقدار الطاقه التي تطلقها وماذا
بعدها عن الارض كما يمكن ان يختلف اللون
من نجمه الى اخرى لان درجات الحراره ليست
كلها متشابهه فعاده تظهر النجوم الساخنه
باللون الابيض او الازرق بينما تظهر
النجوم الاكثر بروده بالام برتقالي او
احمر
عندما تحقق في النجوم المتلالئه في سماء
الليل فانك في الواقع ترى ماضيها بين انها
قد تكون ماتت بالفعل فقياس المسافات بين
النجوم خارج نظامنا الشمسيه يكون بالسنوات
الضوئيه وغالبا فانك تنظر اليها كما كانت
من قبل من المستحيل للبشر معرفه عدد
النجوم الموجوده في الكون لكن يقدر علماء
الفلكنه في ما جارتي الدرب التبانه وحدها
يوجد حوالي 300 مليار نجم
[موسيقى]